muskel sagen sie uns jetzt ändert sich
fast immer etwas
man weiß also gar nicht mancher
vielleicht wenn man ein verstoß begeht
wie teuer kann das ganze für mich werden
wie kann nicht bestraft werden was muss
ich mir jetzt da genau vorstellen wenn
wir ständig neue maßnahmen haben ja
tatsächlich schützt es einen nicht wenn
man nicht die regeln kennt sondern man
sollte sich dann wirklich gut
informieren
denn bei einem regelverstoß da drohen
schnell bußgelder also wir haben gerade
gehört es wird vielleicht erst mal
aufgeklärt aber irgendwann kommen dafür
gelder und die sind unterschiedlich hoch
tatsächlich ist es so dass man als
verbraucher sage ich jetzt mal meistens
mit einem 50 euro bußgeld ganz gut vehr
hat manchmal sind das etwas mehr zum
beispiel in bayern ist wenn man machen
pflicht nicht einhält schon 250 euro
fällig aber zum beispiel werden wir auch
gerade gesehen kinos wenn jetzt jemand
gegen die verordnung ein kino eröffnet
dann ist man schnell im vierstelligen
bereich für den veranstalter also davon
viel empfindlichere bußgelder noch jetzt
gibt es ja bei normalen gesetzen sage
ich mal ein bußgeldkatalog jeder von uns
weiß wo er den findet muss man jetzt
also jede pressekonferenz mit verfolgen
die nachrichten die man lesen gibt es
irgendwo eine übersicht in der dann
jedes mal aktualisiert steht was ich
jetzt darf was nicht und vor allem wie
viel es kostet wenn ich dagegen
verstosse ja letztlich gibt es auch
genau das bei den kommunen regeln also
das heißt auch bußgeldkatalog und
tatsächlich ist es auch so dass man das
ganz gut auf den seiten der jeweiligen
bundesländer findet also das ist die
anlaufstelle wo man sich hinwenden kann
und sollte mich irgendwelche regelungen
im internet die sind oft mit aktuellen
das heißt am besten sie tatsächlich
googeln bußgeld coroner regeln und dann
sein jeweiliges bundesland dann darauf
achten dass man auch die seite des
bundeslandes kommt normalerweise sind da
unter den ersten drei ergebnissen bei
google dann auch wirklich die
offiziellen seiten dann gibt es
normalerweise so eine kleine liste weil
sich eben viel ändert dann darauf achten
dass man die aktuelle liste hat und da
steht dann im prinzip wirklich ganz
schön aufgegliedert verstoß gegen masken
verpflicht verstoß gegen kontaktverbot
falsche angaben im restaurant und dann
steht da eigentlich direkt dahinter das
bußgeld manchmal ist das ganz genau
festgelegt manchmal gibt es einen
bußgeldrahmen also was wie zwischen 50
und 500 euro
das bedeutet dann dass man sozusagen
sich den einzelfall noch mal anguckt ist
es zum beispiel ein wiederholungs
verstoß oder ein besonders schwerer
verstoß dann ist man eher bei 500 euro
und das dank der erste verstoß nicht
ganz so schlimm dann eben bei 50 euro
nun beschäftigt sehe ich frau muss ja
nicht jeder beruflich tatsächlich mit
den gesetzen verordnungen usw
jetzt haben wir gestern gehört die haben
siebeneinhalb stunden oder noch länger
beraten dann gab es ein ergebnis wir
haben uns das alle angeguckt haben jetzt
für berlin gewusst okay so läuft setzte
in den nächsten wochen so läuft über
weihnachten und silvester einen tag
später kommt jetzt gerade die nachricht
ist jetzt doch wieder anders für berlin
also dieses hin und her habe ich die
politik auch eine verpflichtung uns
bürgern gegenüber uns klar zu
informieren oder müssen wir dann
tatsächlich immer in den paragraphen
suchen damit wir kein bußgeld riskieren
ja auch da wieder so die mitte ist
wichtig also natürlich muss man vorher
wissen woran man sich halten muss also
es ist nicht so dass man sagt naja man
kann sich das doch denken sondern man
muss klare regeln vorher aufstellen und
die muss man auch finden können
aber es ist eben auch nicht so dass man
sagt na ja also ich muss mich jetzt auch
gar nicht informieren also darum mittel
dinge und wie wir es gerade gehört haben
da werden die ordnungsämter am anfang
natürlich auch großzügiger sein müssen
also das ist jetzt nicht nur eine
nettigkeit der ordnungsämter sondern
deshalb ist es auch oft so dass eben ja
am anfang erstmal informiert wird bis
eben die neue regelung bei den bürgern
vorgedrungen ist und dann gibts auch
dass bußgelder sie haben ja den begriff
verhältnismäßigkeit jetzt auch schon oft
als nichtjuristen gehört und das ist
genauso ein aspekt dass man wirklich
sagt erst wenn die bürger die regeln
kennen verstanden
dann droht das bußgeld das heißt das ist
auch das was mit diesem rahmen gemeint
ist erst die aufklärung dann 50 euro und
im wiederholungsfall oder wenn schon
länger bekannt ist dann steigern sich
die fußgänger
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren